he lived in a studio apartment in New
York with eight other family members he
joined his family's retail wine business
when he was 14 as a kid here and
thousands of dollars on weekends trading
baseball cards he's Gary Vaynerchuk and
here's my take on his top 50 rules for
success vol 4 enjoy
ok let's kick it off with rule number 1
do what you love maybe you actually love
playing video games more than starting
an app company when I was growing up
playing video games was a waste of time
today I think we can all agree a
professional eSports superstar for the
next 50 years probably behind proper
football and basketball is going to be
the biggest athlete in our world this is
nothing you could see 7 or 10 years ago
you must you must you owe it to yourself
to make sure that you're building a
company around what you love not because
cryptocurrency
is the current fad when you chase money
you lose always and forever
even when you achieve the money this is
how humans are wired rule number 2 over
the liver my great legacy in my
aspiration to be someone that gets
written about like Robin Hood is giving
it for free like the thing that I if
somebody asked me what are you most
proud of
I'm literally giving away all my best
for free I don't know what else to say a
lot of people that kind of look like me
build audience to the masses but then
try to sell to that audience right
here's the four thousand dollar ebook
here's the come to my mastermind what I
do is back to your analogy that's why I
thought of it too I do business with
Chase and Budweiser and Triple A List
celebrities but for the masses it's free
I'm obsessed with over-delivering it's
why I say yes to like this in the first
place the fact that I get one of the
emails I get a day and I get a lot of
them that says I was at I was suicidal
like wheels that's heavy that trumps
anything I will ever do professionally
one one person telling you that they
were going to take their life and that
your videos in podcast may
them not is disproportionate greater
than if I bought all 32 NFL teams and I
mean that rule number three be patient
everybody gets hyped when I hide them
like this then they do it for four days
a week a month
nothing happens there like that did you
look carefully at the 2009 and 2010
tweets how much engagement they had yeah
did you or not you know that some of
those tweets only had two likes and a
share people forget what my 2009 and 10
looked like everybody starts with only
one like here's the tactical part you
put a ton of content eventually
something kind of goes viral and you
spend a load of money against it because
people prove that they gave rule number
four be practical please understand my
biggest truth here today which is if you
are not sharing your thoughts your
process your journey your progress to
achieving your goals the stories you
want to tell about your startup product
service if you are not communicating to
the world and if you're not thinking
about what's valuable to them not what's
valuable to you when you communicate and
that is a very big point I'll say one
more time if you are not communicating
to the world and when you're
communicating if you're not thinking
about what's valuable to them versus
what you're putting out for yourself you
are basically irrelevant in a 20-19
world as much as it may be difficult for
many in this room if you are not living
through here you are not known this is
the game if you are under estimating
this and when I say under estimating
this if you have not made a significant
commitment to producing content for the
one of seven apps or websites that 80%
of this entire region spends a
disproportionate amount of time
penetrating and listening and consuming
you are becoming vastly vastly
irrelevant
also if you want to have more confidence
check at my 254 confident series it's
free the link to join is in the
description below we are strongest we're
really strong we're just being sold that
we're not because there's a lot of money
the reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
in a success world please understand
that success is happiness not net
dollars in rule number 5 take shots like
Gary I hit up I deemed all the
influencers like you told me nobody
responded I'm like how many they're like
130 I'm like good there's about 9
million more no because that's not the
way to position it right because most
people want answer that because somebody
who's got an audience that's all they
see I would say how can I help you you
see where I'm going
like like yo I with you like how can I
help you yes you do you have your time
you never know
d-roc didn't have any leverage do you
rock asked me four times and then
finally said yeah fine make me a video
not even that mindset and then this all
happened because of it that's real
that's real that's the story that's the
story he has to be four times I want to
make a video for you he was a video I
wasn't making content like that then and
but it was in my mind and by the 4 times
like you know what ok ok make me a free
video show me here we are now he's the
the word that people you like people
literally say literally affirms
literally people like that my dear ox
name is Rick you know deep name it's
real and and you know what I said this
at the time to the erectus I mean you're
gonna impact people like you now awesome
it is for people that love to do it to
do it you me people wanted to make
documentaries their whole lives yet only
74 people a year get to do them and now
74,000 people you get to do it all it
takes is one person rule number six know
yourself I just don't care about the
money yeah like I'm fine making 47
thousand a year and reading all the
comments on Instagram
that I was a loser and lost at all
interested interested so what it'll be
remembered for the end then I gave a
hell of a lot more than I took I want to
be I want to be the greatest
entrepreneur of all time because
entrepreneurship is what I do and I
think the way to do that is to a build
big businesses and exits and companies
and put the points on the board right
but Who I am
right yeah I mean like like I want to
inspire the most entrepreneurs to be
happy not just successful okay like
there's so many people were gonna be
unhappy making a million a year that
would have been thrilled making 6:30
rule number seven hustle the reason
we're sitting here today is I decided
from 2007 to 2011 to spend four to eight
hours a day replying to people on
Twitter that weren't even talking to me
you could type in the hash the name of
that town and then go in an Instagram
and then go to places click it and see
every photo that's been posted in your
town in that town you could then go look
at the photo could be her at a goodwill
saying huge score
you could reply and say good 7 to 150 on
a stapler go girl
now all of a sudden she's just a normal
human she only gets 6 comments to begin
with she's like who's this man she
clicks she goes your bio is I sell homes
she's like cool nice guy I hope he's not
weird and she's out but the 97th person
that does that goes he seems nice goes
in the funnel you put out a good piece
of content like I'm gonna DM him I'm
thinking about selling my home what
people don't understand is how much work
I put to even begin the process of being
Who I am today 2007 2011 is a long time
ago for a lot of people that year I
decided to go on Twitter search and
anybody that talked about wine I jumped
in and talked to them how did I get here
hand-to-hand combat when the rate love
the process to build a meaningful
company takes a very long time is very
difficult and more importantly what has
happened
startup community all those wonderful
startups back there everybody now is
pandering to venture capital or to
raising capital not to actually building
a business every day
thank you it's important and thank you
so much for jumping on that it's
important because let me let me tell you
why in two thousand six seven eight nine
I was taking all of my money and
investing in Tumblr and Facebook and
Twitter and uber and all these things
that I did very well with and why over
the last four years I've invested very
little very carefully because there's a
disconnect right now and there's
illusions of the reality if you stand
here or sit here today and there is
nothing that you could think about other
than building a business because the
process of building a business is your
happiness not what a successful business
allows you to buy well then you're a
purebred entrepreneur rule number nine
have humility and perspective if you can
have perspective proper macro
perspective and you can have micro you
know practitioner ship you will be happy
and win
yeah I really believe that yeah having
the humility and the audacity back to
your contradiction but yeah I mean
that's how I got to clouds and dirt you
know because I've always been fascinated
by that about me which is the things I'm
willing to do right now that are below
by pave grade this podcast this is super
scrutinized by the people around me
right it's like why are you doing this
we don't have 15 minutes for very
important your letting money opportunity
VIPs why are you doing this I don't know
like intuitively when we were talking I
thought it was a good idea and I want to
I think you know in my massive person
you know perspective giving back I look
you're going to leverage me being on
this show for sure and that makes me
feel good that's me giving back
this is a bigger thing giving you these
15 minutes than me giving you $15,000
for your app for me it's easier to write
the check
so so for me humility and like
perspective like I don't think I don't
know how many very busy people are
running around knowing that they need to
put change into the bucket of giving
back in their time not their money
rule number 10 stop caring what people
think there is nothing nothing more
difficult than navigating your life
based on somebody else's opinion you
actually care about what your dad or mom
or grandma or husband or wife or
daughter or son is gonna say about you
if you do this thing it doesn't matter
what they think when you're 92 and
you're sitting there you're not gonna
give a [ __ ] about what
punk man 96 had to say or even what your
aunt had to say who's miserable because
she never got hers so she's trying to
keep you down negative people latch on
to positive people and try to seclude
them from the world because that's their
little energy in work I see it every day
in life I see it every day it's just
what it is
I hate how many people judge other
people without having all the context
every time you judge you make yourself
vulnerable 99.9% of people that you
judge or have opinions on you have no
idea what is actually happening in their
lives like you don't know what's going
on in somebody's home everybody sucks at
something right like we all have
shortcomings and for me it's like why
don't we just audit that like why don't
we just look at it that way and be like
all right well I'm good at this but I'm
not gonna dad like everybody's so
absolute are you really really really
not gonna live your life based on
somebody's anonymous icon feedback but
you suck they suck go do your thing I'm
not living a life where you allow other
people's judgement to dictate your
behavior rule number 11 have self
awareness outside of spending time with
my inner family and closest friends and
outside a garage selling and watching
the Jets there's nothing I'd rather do
than work a 15 hour day you're self
aware you know you and I always have
this why I shoveled snow and did
lemonade and I washed cars as a
seven-year-old all day long on August
9th cuz it's what I like and I'm not
gonna judge somebody who wants to work
9:00 to 5:00 be on 13
softball teams and play video games all
day and make 42k year if she and he are
pumped as they're equal to me because I
know a bunch of miserable billionaires
and I know a lot of unhappy 55 ka years
and everything in between rule number 12
give I literally get 700 emails a month
when somebody knows I'm gonna be in some
town like Gary like in the title like
great news I will pick you up from the
airport and drive you to your hotel I
want to really give I'm like you I'm
like that's $48 uber ride I need my
peace and quiet to catch up with the
work when I land from the flight you
don't want to give me a ride you want me
to give you consulting for 45 minutes
while we drive you can save your lunch
that you want me to buy that you want to
buy for me and all that and I'm
fascinated by you know a lot of times
I'll hit up those kids they're like yo
it's not working I'm like because you're
not giving when you're DMing somebody
you're asking you're trying to take like
you know it's it's really it's a really
funny thing to try to get somebody to
click on what the definition of giving
is and people struggle with selflessness
they really do they live they struggle
with not being selfish in the disguise
of giving and i think ii think the
reason i want to talk about it and keep
thrown out these examples is once you're
aware of it people aren't even
oftentimes aren't aware you know but
once you become aware of it i actually
think it changes the entire framework of
this conversation rule number 13 don't
worry what others think
you're about you're valuing other
people's opinions my question is why do
you look so sharp do you love it or do
you think it's reject something to other
people you got a break you got to figure
that out the only reason people
overthink is thing cuz they worry about
to judge me
I go fast because I don't for real like
real yeah what am I going fast but only
one thing that I'm just really really
knowing grass and you should do it and
if you don't know it
hedge it upfront you can start the video
it's like I'm not sure I'm talking about
it
Wow thank you so much doing the game if
you're not doing nothing's happening
right and I don't want
[ __ ] and thinking rule number 14
don't be delusional so you talk patience
to write that people should be patient
in in the pursuit of their goals at what
point does patient just become delusion
a lot of times oh so what are the hacks
or the tips that you for them to be
self-aware to know when to just why
don't when is patience just right or
have you been running the same thing for
seven years and nothing good has
happened you're delusional let's start
there
that's a test I believe in that if
there's been no progress in your rap
career or in your art or your video blog
and you've been doing it every day for
seven years as hard as you can and
nothing has happened
the market has spoken that's one way now
is that four years is that two years do
people jump off like you need to see
some level of progress to keep you
having blood in the water to get you
going but sometimes there is a
breakthrough because if the machine is
in between you and the market well then
you got to be discovered but the reason
now I think it's more pure is because
SoundCloud and Spotify and YouTube and
Shopify and Amazon now you get the
feedback loop so fast and it isn't the
arbitrary subjective called the reason
that took some of the greatest stars of
all time
eleven years to break through is because
other people had say people didn't see
Gaga's talent they shook thought she was
weird somebody thought she wasn't weird
she breaks out AG Lady gaga today she
goes on YouTube and Spotify direct and
the market speaks quicker people are
more famous quicker now if they have the
talent
cuz nobody's in the middle this is why I
talk in general terms on content of
course cuz I don't have the context but
if somebody sat here and I listened for
40 minutes I would tell them if they're
delusional or just impatient and most
people are impatient and delusional
remember 15 chase happiness if I can
replace the word millionaire with happy
and I'm crazy I think I can pull it off
what do you do Gary one let's say you're
at a location or you're a point in your
life that you're obviously you need you
need to pay bills but you're no longer
happy what what are you you need to
change your bills okay okay you need to
not buy a fresh hoodie you may need to
move into a apartment
I'm being dead serious one of the other
conversations I'm having is change your
bills okay you know if you're not happy
but you got bills why don't you look at
your bills happiness no dude it's
everything
rule number 16 be honest I think getting
a sense of like what are you actually up
to is super important and if you're like
I love what I do well then you should
invest in that beast forever if you're
like I just want some money and buy a
home in Jamaica and live there well then
maximize it and squeeze it I think it's
a very important thing I just don't
think most people know what they're
doing when I say know what they're doing
I mean macro like why do you have this
business correct it doesn't need to be a
super complicated answer it's a
lifestyle business this is a legacy is
this you want to make as much money as
possible flip it and do something else
like if you are honest with yourself and
everybody around you employees will work
for you if you tell them that you're
gonna drive everybody into the ground
and flip it because some of them may say
well I just need the paycheck or they
may say oh cool I want to be in flipped
or cool I just want to watch her do it
and then maybe I'll do it like truth
really is good it's really really good
rule number 17 take action people like
listen to your content and consume it
they like the feeling of being motivated
but then there's work that has to be
done after it and I don't think people
like that feeling yeah and I think
that's why I talk about trying to find
things you like not making money the
variable of happiness you know this like
I make content that's literally says
stop watching me go do it and then they
go and watch somebody else that charges
them for the information so like yeah I
mean like people what people like
consuming motivational content because
they think they're actually doing
something I think it's like watching
somebody else work out rule number 18 be
good at timing I will tell you the
biggest thing that I've gotten better at
the lessons I learned as a kid even
though I was right
I literally built
dad's entire business strategy for wine
library when I took over ninety nine
eight I'm not the this this is true that
by the year two thousand which is twenty
four months four men everybody would
walk into our liquor store with a phone
and have technology that would give them
the price of every product in the
country in order of best price and
that's literally how I decided to sell
everything a cost that anybody knew and
then build up other brands it was great
because it really worked because we were
the price leader of everyone anybody
wanted we still don't do that it is now
2019 we have closest capability we have
that capability ish there is something
called wine searcher if you're a big
wine buyer that aggregates like it it's
there but it's not one person will walk
into wine library this year that's by
where people look up stuff on Amazon you
know so I was wrong about timing what I
got better what I'm good at now people
you know so right I'm good at timing
that's why I didn't bet on VR that's why
I don't bet on AR that's why I don't bet
on machine learning or things of that
nature I know every one of those things
is gonna happen the question is when
rule number nineteen learned to deal
with negativity I like reading my
negative comments way more than my
positive ones I mean it I mean it and I
don't think there are trolls and haters
I really don't I think that they've
consumed me in a context and I need to
be thoughtful about what they're
thinking now I do believe I equally
believe that if you're taking time to
consume people's other people's content
on the internet and then you have the
energy to leave terrible comments you're
cut you're in a sad place yourself you
know so usually when I read like Gary
Vee your snake oil salesman my first
default is okay why do they interpret
this octet this way but even before I go
there my alpha even before that my first
default is like I feel bad for that
person
rule number twenty turn adversities into
strengths
friend Sammy here
I'm trying to get out of that right
if you say I did poorly in high school
with my parents there's something
interesting you may in hindsight in
years to come when you get older see it
as a huge advantage when I hear stories
of that much adversity the amount of
people that I know that have gone on to
shine first of all for you to be this
young and have the aspirations to break
through instead of dwell and be like I
got it's over huge I think if you keep
building on that and like I actually
think being bad at high school is
foundationally a core reason most people
end up being successful and so the more
you start thinking about your
adversities as strengths the more the
reality of what you're trying to achieve
is gonna happen
rule number 21 love what you do I mean
that's a real entrepreneur she or he
loves it so much they couldn't be I mean
my actions have spoken long before
entrepreneurship was cool I could I was
not capable of being a student because
of my deep passion for entrepreneurship
it was baseball cards it was baseball
cards that didn't allow me to be a good
student I was incapable of sitting in
class and not dreaming about selling bo
Jackson cards it took me over but for
some reason when you're an athlete and
you're missing a bunch of school for
because you're a great athlete or when
you're Beyonce being home school right
that makes sense but not for
entrepreneurs right doesn't seem like
you're allowed to miss a ton of school
if you're an unbelievable actor actress
singer athlete missing Normal School is
something that all of us in this room
and listening right now understand
you're like oh yeah that's what happens
like you're the best quarterback in the
world yeah you got a throw with the
quarterback you miss first class you
know but not for entrepreneurs but
that's who I was rule number 22 surround
yourself with optimism
I'm thought real quick being thoughtful
about the future is amazing but not
letting it [ __ ] you is the key yeah
because my problem I would think so
first in future I always start worrying
about stuff yeah I want to accomplish
before I leave this earth years from now
that I wanted to do like oh it's great
to have ambition yeah yeah that's that's
but if you cast too much judgment on
yourself on a day to day on how you're
reaching that ambition you're gonna
[ __ ] yourself but the fact that you
understand
that that is your perspective means
you're on the cusp of fixing it the only
thing that I've ever seen really work in
this scenario where your DNA and your
experiences has made you look half glass
full pessimistic versus optimistically
blind is to fundamentally surround
yourself with optimistic people you got
a cut out pessimistic in negativity and
you got to add on optimism and
positivity it's as simple as that
you guys should be looking around at
each other and whoever else is in here
and like in order who's the most
optimist and not don't there's a real
fine line between delusion and optimism
I'm gonna be in the league but they're
not even practicing
so that's delusion I'm gonna be in a
league and maybe you don't see it but
you see them at least doing free throws
5:00 a.m. to 6:00 a.m. every morning
before they go on the bus you know at
least he's trying and it's and and the
more difficult your circumstances are
the more likely you're around pessimism
but my number one piece of advice of
leaving here is whoever the most
optimistic person is here become more
friendly with them straight up
rule number 23 have good intent like
Gary you're such a narcissist all your
content is you I'm like I'm trying to
say something to people that I hope they
take and I expect nothing from them I
ask nothing of them and I hope they take
it and do something with it
that is the form of how I know how to
communicate it I'm sorry I'm in the
video he's like you like if you were
trying to get everybody to watch so that
youth everybody here thought you were
the best guy so then you could
rope-a-dope um and get him into some
sort of like $5,000 a month Club to be
good then your face if you don't and you
live your life and you do it and then
you die you're the best I'm not joking I
think intent is the thing I put my head
on the pillow I think I'm gonna make
mistakes every day I will make mistakes
I am a human I will do things that are
wrong I am a human I will say I'm sorry
when I'm wrong I will take losses when I
deserve them but the intent is amazing
like it's why I'm so calm it's why I'm
happiest it's why I'm so grateful it's
why I'm able to give because I'm so
fulfilled that like I give out of guilt
gratitude right like I'm just I know
exactly what's happening with me and I'm
trying to get people to change their
perspective but I'm really not trying to
like I like the feeling of somebody
getting benefit from something you said
that's what I'm sure that gets you
excited like watching somebody go do
something meaningful because they
thought it was cool that you cut
somebody like that's an incredible
feeling yeah it's amazing yeah he gives
me all the hope in the world rule number
24 put in no work
I hear fake manipulations of my story
just one more time because we're having
an on-the-record day I walked into my
dad's business doing 3.8 million dollars
in sales grew it to a 60 million dollar
business
so you weren't handed it like some other
people said of course not I left the 34
years guys if I was handed a 60 million
dollar business why would I start
vaynermedia in the conference room of
Buddy Media because I didn't have enough
money for rent know what I did unlike
all you was I gave the 12 best years of
my life to my parents who I loved the
most
built them a 60 million dollar business
and walked at 34 with no money now what
now what now what so yes people say easy
for you to say that's and by the way
it's what everybody does and by the way
cool fine
easy because I have talent that all
respect but I put it in the work wheel
number 25 chase happiness let me tell
you one thing about teaching or anything
else that doesn't make you a million
dollars a year the most upset not happy
people I know have the most money that I
know this we need to start changing a
conversation to happiness not money you
can make 47 thousand a year and have
much more stuff than somebody makes 280
that depends on how much you spend you
might not be in a position to buy every
new off white on a teacher salary but
the question is do you need that the
reality is most people need it just to
flex in front of somebody cuz they're
insecure
once you don't give a [ __ ] about
anybody's opinion you don't need you
ain't gonna buy anything you need
nothing
that's straight up man young guys bye
cuz they're insecure they want to look
home from their friends they want to get
a girl it's not super complicated least
complicated of all time
rule number 26 go on the offense I tell
everybody that I meet along the way that
I think is authentic put your two
fingers in your ears execute in
perpetuity and let the chips fall that's
the only way you'll ever be able to
achieve something remarkable because
when you are doing anything interesting
or game-changing or like different
you're only gonna I only been booed my
whole life every single thing I've done
basically from school to professionally
I mean I took I don't know if I've ever
taken more heat for not opening a second
liquor store with my dad like the entire
liquor industry which was my life right
my dad's liquor industry in New Jersey
was my life every one of those people
ridiculed the [ __ ] out of me for selling
liquor on the computer you're pouring
all that money and selling liquor and
the computer you should open a second
liquor store right so like I think
there's certain people entrepreneurs
givers politicians there's millions of
people different kinds of teachers
there's certain people who are just
capable of doing that and I think the
reason I talk a lot about it is my hope
is if this one answer can let them hear
one less voice that's moving the needle
because you're either on offense or
you're on defense and dwelling about
other people's opinions of how you live
your life is defense rule number 27
provide value you always get the same
questions your answers are usually the
same which is a good thing it means
you're staying consistent
yeah but I'm wondering how many of these
questions are just self validation
questions or they already know the
answer to it
a lot is that does that trouble you at
all no I'm I don't think when you're
trying to provide value that you get to
decide what the value is that's actually
giving see people don't get it like Gary
Vee you're fooling yourself mmm look a
little bit deeper like like I have no
ambition to dictate the value that I
provide I have ambition of providing the
value the person wants so if somebody
wants to roll up and they need four
minutes of my time
while I'm running to my next meeting and
I'm busy but because nothing gets me
more hyped and like bringing humans
value that they need validation even
though I know 92% of time that's
literally what's gonna happen in this
micro moment I'm thrilled to do it
because then if they go do it they start
a podcast and get an interview with me
rule number 28 be close to the end
consumer you should definitely do that
no no because you need to know what the
you're talking about your business I've
consistently stayed consistent on this
which is if you don't know the craft
how are you judging the people you're
hiring that's different
sure everything else you doing you
should give away good well I just
contextualized it for you how are you
gonna find those seven hours a day to
get great at social your doing something
now I assume know why coz on autopilot I
got it so what are you doing you should
do this because the products are not the
variable of success the knowledge of
understanding how to communicate to the
end consumer are there's nothing more
important than mean close to the end
consumer nothing else matters
there's another big thing that's gonna
happen you're gonna make a thousand way
better products after you're done with
this because you're gonna be in the
trenches and not in a siloed ivory tower
you're gonna have much better intuition
on the product rule number 29 be
thoughtful I'm passionate about this
haters trolls think I think people are
quickly defaulting immediately if
somebody doesn't agree with them and
calling them a troll or a hater and they
they maybe but I think it's very I mean
I'm genuinely meanness I take a lot of
heat because I put myself very out there
but I genuinely have become great
friends with many people that [ __ ] on me
or have come to understandings it's very
important you know like to be thoughtful
like look you somebody who might say
you're a friend off and you're just
trying to build a business you don't
know if they're ant committed suicide
and that's like hurt them in their heart
and they're just and you they know
you're a business if they knew you
before and you're been entrepreneur you
know you don't know I just don't think
we know I think we're just I just I
don't know I'm getting very passionate
about judgment I'm still in my working
stages on it but like it's crazy I'm
just like I have opinions I'm a normal
human being I got quick I got hot takes
on everything but I know they're both
because I know even the people I know
super well even d-roc who I know super
well man do I not know a lot and so if
that's the case the hell am i doing with
your one piece of content or your one
question or right like you can go on
intuition all this but like I think we
need to be more thoughtful about push
back because it's been very helpful for
me like I think I don't know I think
it's important rule number 30 make stuff
happen if you hate your Monday through
Friday you're in big trouble
you're big trouble
I hate Friday I really do I'm blown away
by people celebrating the end of the
week it breaks my heart my friends like
live for Friday night like they know
they got their wait like Monday morning
is the worst like at its basic form if
you genuinely celebrate Friday you need
to rethink your entire game to live your
life where you love Friday night
Saturday and Sunday and despise Monday
through Thursday or Friday morning is
devastating to me because you're wasting
too much of your life and I'm trying to
put pressure on the conversation to say
if you love Friday that much then you
need to really look at Monday through
Thursday if you literally start your
week being sad and it gets progressively
better your Anna put you have a problem
we spend way too much time in our lives
doing our jobs when you're spending more
than half your life to work in it's
important that that thing is on point
it's just a math game if you're spending
83 percent of your time 72 percent of
your times 64 percent of your time on
something you hate that's devastating
how do people not understand that when
you eliminate sleeping it is what you do
you basically live to work hmm if you're
unhappy where are you going if you are
like running to Friday night that means
you're miserable Monday through Friday
and I lived that life I used to run into
Friday when I was in school and I hated
Sunday night with my entire heart I
lived for snow days for like a decade
like for a decade the only thing I gave
up about was please cannanore Easter
come through and eliminate school the
thought that that is so many people's
work lives which will be the
disproportionate percentage of how they
live their lives breaks my heart
it breaks my heart I'm not making this
video to share how lucky I am or how
cool it is that I love what I'm doing I
just don't understand why people
relegate into losing mentality and just
thinking they can you can't because you
want to be on the bowling team or
softball and play video games that's why
you can't there's plenty of time get you
done now you watch a little Gary Vee you
get a
motivated you decide to actually work on
Friday night but then you wake up
Saturday right and you're feeling good
and then you grab your phone and you go
on Instagram and the first thing you see
is your boys are the people that you
look up to in the club pretty girls
jewelry money and and all of a sudden
your phone gap you know motivations
exciting but the practicality of an
execution it is even more importantly in
so I sit here today and I make this
video if I can get one person to be like
he's right like what the hell am I doing
here
Friday cannot be the best day of the
week because if it is you've already
lost and you need to figure out how to
fix that whether that side hustle from
7:00 p.m. to midnight and whether that's
networking from 7 to 9 p.m. with other
job opportunities and whether that's
taking a financial step backwards to
take a job that you love that you can
grow up into please recognize the world
we're living in this is not your
grandpappy's life we have the Internet
you can make happen you can build
businesses or side hustles your
grandparents couldn't do the things you
can do your career enhancing didn't have
the internet your grandparents couldn't
be practical 9:00 to 5:00 then come home
you know do their family thing and then
from 7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the morning do
something online that could have been
the thing that switched them out of
their nine-to-five and created their
freedom didn't have that option
we do everybody in this room does we
live in a 24/7 world and people get mad
at me again because like Jerry I look
forward to the weekends I love my family
it's not about money you're such an
[ __ ] it's family like no no you're
not listening I'm talking about if you
genuinely dislike what you do so much
that you beg for Friday look and the
only way you're gonna work 15 hours a
day and pay that sacrifice to be away
from your loved ones and travel and
hustle is if you're doing something
around the subject matter that you live
and breathe and die for
please take this permission this energy
to start crying and don't give up be
patient please do not waste the next 5
10 15 20 30 years of your life and
allocate 30 40 50 60 percent of their
time to something that you hear can end
each and every week rule number 31
surround yourself with positivity I
believe one of the great ways to mix
things up is what you listen to and who
you surround yourself with I would I'm
unbelievably passionate about people
finding more optimistic practical
friends and I and I think optimism gets
can get can slide into delusion which is
why I say optimistic go practical
there's only offense and defense there's
only the force in the dark side right
and I think that um right now people are
a lot of people are choosing to be
driven by fear and negativity without
realizing it and so if you're listening
right now my biggest thing is start
leaning into a little bit more optimism
and positivity
rule number 32 don't have any regrets
when I was a little kid in Edison New
Jersey when grandparents came over I
would go play with the grandparents a
lot a lot mainly was because I lost
three of my four grandparents as a kid
and the number one thing I learned in
the first 20 years of my life spending
more time with old people than most kids
is the biggest thing I fear is regret
regret is scary resentment is very scary
the biggest reason I push kids to do
what they want versus what they parents
want is because I'd rather them and
their parents have five or six or seven
years of bad than 80 because it gets
very ugly when you're 60 and they're 80
and you lived your life based on what
they wanted and now you resent them it
gets real ugly real fast
I would rather you have the pain for the
next five or six years of fighting and
then have one of two things happen which
I think both are amazing
number one you were right you were right
and you are an amazing fashion designer
not an engineer and you built a real
company and your parents are going to be
very very proud or you were wrong you
suck at fashion design nobody liked it
but at least for yourself you never have
to live the rest of your life asking
yourself what if you win both ways
rule number 33 focus on the consumer
what can some of the young entrepreneurs
learn from the big companies and what
could be companies learn from the young
entrepreneurs that's a great question
and honestly I would argue that that is
a core strength of mine that I play in
both worlds and so I'm able to like see
the common themes I think big companies
can learn that process for the sake of
process is the worst thing of all time
and that's all they've become and that
long-term marathon running and building
a business is better than every 90 days
but they're stuck because they pander to
Wall Street
I think startups are impatient
underestimates scale pander to beasts
you know big companies pay honor to Wall
Street startups pay honor to be seized
neither panders to the end consumer I
genuinely believe that because I pander
to the end consumer the audience that I
am Who I am
Wine Library was what Wine Library was
vaynermedia is everybody panders two
things in the middle
mean nothing rule number 34 show your
worth today you feel it yep and you know
what and you know what's funny like a
lot of times we were like I know my
worth
you're being actually more thoughtful
than that you're putting yourself in a
position to allow the market to
establish your worth yeah everybody
knows they're worth the amount of people
there's millions of people running
around saying I know my worth and never
do anything because the market doesn't
give them the leverage to create worth
what I like about what you're doing is
you're not sitting in your room
ideologically saying I know my worth
you're putting in work to get money to
put yourself in a position you're doing
it the right way no it's real I mean it
no I need it I mean it like I think I
know my worth it's like when people
always say look I'm not willing to work
for free I know my worth and I'm like
you you go like you have cute you're
winning on you're building a foundation
on humility you're actually working and
I'm sure you know I'm not sure but I
assume you need to have a job that gives
you flexibility so you're probably not
making a billion dollars a year exactly
yep and so like I just I just wish more
youngsters would follow your blueprint
people are just not willing to eat and
like it's just entitlement everybody
just decided that they're the best
rapper in the world and they just leave
comments on rappers instagrams and be
like you haven't heard me yet I'm the
best cool show me really were 35 build
your business around your hobbies I
think a lot of people should build
around their interest in their hobbies
businesses because I think it's a more
it's a I think it's a better life to be
happy and make 200 thousand a year for
fifty five thousand four five thousand
and be happy then to make a million and
be miserable I really believe that it's
not sustainable unhappiness is not
sustainable but there's a lot of ways to
do it I'll give you an example if you
love football soccer football right okay
so that's your passion right now when
you think about a business when you go
back to the market do you build 4 3 3
and a huge Instagram page do you build a
direct-to-consumer soccer ball business
do you buy the football jerseys and
resell them on Facebook marketplace you
see where I'm going
so I feel like there's a way to do both
and my opinion is if you love football
then you're gonna be willing to be up at
11 o'clock at night DMing and trying to
sell football jerseys whereas if you're
trying to do cryptocurrency because you
think there's money there you're not
interested you're there for the money
rule number 36 love the game I try to
convince nobody of anything I've zero
interest in convincing anybody that
anything I say is right like zero like
people always like Gary how do you
convince the clients to do social mean
I'm like I don't I tell them what I
believe and hopefully they'll do
something about it and if not then I
can't wait to see him in seven years
when I could tell them I told you so you
know like like I really feel like I win
either way every time I really feel like
that's what happens I'll either be
historically correct and I'll raise you
all these kids that are not signing with
Boehner Sports right now right because
me my brother have this sports agency
where we're coming in 2nd a lot because
they're enamored but we're still new and
this agency that's been doing it for 40
years and did it for my favorite player
feels like a smarter bet it's crazy I
love it there's a thing that came out
about Kobe and Dwyane Wade this weekend
where Dwyane Wade was talking about how
he broke Kobe's nose in an all-star game
and he's like he like called him like a
day later and Kobe he was like no no I
love it I love that you broke my nose
and everyone just talked about how crazy
Kobe was and I was like watching that
videos like I so understand that the
only thing I like better than winning a
piece of business is losing it I
genuinely enjoy it more rule number 37
overcome adversity
versity either crumbles you or becomes
foundational to your success I you know
I always think about that picture where
it looks like two people kissing or like
a glass of champagne like I'm you know
like the flute I'm so fascinated by
perspective the amount of people who
decide in your situation when you hurt
your back that's C C it was just about
to get good but God took it away from me
and just give up is a lot I mean that
and then people who like go into a
wheelchair because they're paralyzed and
decide that's the platform that they're
gonna use to like change the world
I'm just so fast about the perspective
rule number 38 chase happiness you know
what I think is a better advantage than
being born into something being born
into nothing I'm on the record remember
I said it can't wait to watch it in 20
years the internet the way it is today
I'd rather have zero than a hundred
million people that have zero like this
guy's an idiot that's cuz you don't talk
to trust fund babies I do I talk to
trust fund babies they DM me I meet them
in real life because in my business
career they're sad do you know what do
you know what it's like to talk to a
human being that looks at you at 22
years old and says no matter what I do
no matter what I do for the next 80
years it will never be my own
accomplishment everybody will always say
I was handed it and I'm done you know
what kind of level of depression cocaine
and partying until you die that leads to
a lot
both sides are oz2 come the other side
and by the way nor do I expect anybody
that grew up the way I did in a studio
apartment in Queens to have sadness for
Richard Thompson the third they will say
what I always hear which is cool I'll
cry in my Ferrari that's cuz you don't
know what crying is because smiling in
your Toyota is way better than crying in
your Ferrari but you can stay confused
and when you get there why don't you
call good old Gary and tell me how it
actually feels crying is never
acceptable not interesting aka being sad
and depressed and not happy people
confused if you think of Ferrari or some
hot Supremes or
pretty girl or boy or a yacht is gonna
make you happy
your
not smart about life rule number 39 play
for yourself for me personally it's when
I go to sleep do I feel good about
myself to myself I'm the judge and jury
not my mom not my wife not my kids and
definitely not you
me me for me that's why I love the Rocky
with Drago right it's a moment that
stuck with me as a kid and now 13 years
later I understand it when he's standing
there and he's telling the Soviet
government you weren't in the ring I was
fighting for myself not for you in this
country I don't I didn't understand I
thought it's because I was born in
Russia and I love the Rocky movies that
but but 25 years later somehow on some
during a shower a flight I remember when
I remember when I understood I'm like
that's why 13-year old me thought that
was such an important moment I'm playing
for me I'm the judge and the jury
rule number forty used the 7921 rule you
put 80 percent of your energy to squeeze
Instagram 150 percent yeah and you spend
20 percent of your energy tasting
YouTube podcasts direct-mail conferences
shows but you won't be because the 80
percent of the tension has to go
somewhere else and you've been tasting
it on the twenty percent when the 80
percent goes away on Instagram where do
you think all this attention goes on the
show you been tasting when I came out
said like snapchats work yeah popping
I've been tasting snapchat for two years
I saw the Khaled moment and I looked at
numbers like this is the moment but I've
been tasting it I've been tasting
LinkedIn for four years now I'm telling
people it's happening I'm still I'm
still tasting snapchat you would solve
snapchat I don't know yes I'm saying
that I'm saying you're vulnerable cuz
you don't have the 20% going hard make
your 80% other thing that's really
working the best aka Instagram yeah go a
hundred fifty percent hard on if not 80
person everybody's doing 100% Instagram
going 70% hard got it right
net 70 points
I'm saying go 80% on Instagram not a
hundred percent yeah go hard got it go
hard leaving you 20% to go hard on
Twitter and snap and all this why do I
know what's going on it's snap and
Linkedin right now cuz I've been doing
this even though I'm the guy year I'm
going harder than everybody right
podcast email text messaging up limit
over here what about YouTube yeah
nobody's playing here and then everybody
that's playing here is going 70% so go
150% on the thing that's popping yeah
taste everything else at all times so
when this does decline yeah you're all
in here you're all in here you've tasted
on peach or oh you've tasted on Barrow
and every single person that signed up
followed me but then I I was because I
was active and first how did you know to
be first because I'm always living in a
20 percent all right god rule number 41
have thick skin I got very lucky I grew
up in a situation where I was losing
from day one we were humble immigrants I
got picked on for not speaking English I
wasn't a good student
I wasn't been excelling athlete which
allowed me to create an enormous amount
of thick skin to doing things and not
being scared of judgment because I was
being judged from the beginner do you
help noxious lis thick my skin is when
it comes to business thank you
what anybody says about me or thinks of
me or thinks what I'm doing I'm willing
to go work picking up garbage right now
right now it just doesn't seem so crazy
to me
people get fancy I'm still doing the
[ __ ] that got me here even though people
think I got somewhere you may think I
got somewhere I don't think I'm
somewhere I'm still in the same process
rule number 42 live your hobby this is
my first time I love doing this like
I've said it over and over you can
probably clip 13 different times I've
said in the last month like this is my
hobby yeah this is my passions what I'd
love to do I love building businesses
this is fun for me
like I'd rather be doing this than
playing for night I'd rather be doing
this than skiing I'd rather be doing
this in rock climbing yoga cooking
watching Game of Thrones this is my
hobby
most people don't do their hobby as
their profession like I just don't think
most people are living their hobby
rule number 43 be practical my dad is a
100% default cynic my mom is a 100%
optimist and I understand it both so I
look at everything through both of their
eyes and so I understand so I you know
I've I I'm to be honest I'm I'm grateful
that I skewed more towards optimism it's
what entrepreneurship needs you're
blindly optimistic like you can't do
this an entrepreneur does unless you're
delusional and optimistic right but be
but I was so grateful that I got into my
dad's sphere of cynicism right because
what it did was it allowed me not to
become delusional there was a level of
practicality then over later did I think
practicality is amazing I think I'm I'm
crazy practical it's why for 25 years
I've built businesses never borrowed
money never lost money like I'm always
practical so and I think that's a
kissing cousin sometimes the cynicism
and I think you know I have a friend
who's like I'm cynic I'm like you're
practical
you've got a little hint of cynicism and
I think you know there's you know I'm
optimistic but I'm not delusional
rule number 44 go all-in what was the
hardest lesson for you to learn with
regard to putting up content like
whether were something you were doing
that you shouldn't be or something that
you were that you should have been
that's a great question you know what's
funny it's back to kind of how I answer
that question I'm so not good at
thinking about like the negatives of
things like it's hard for me to even
recall I first of all I was very early
right I I was one of the first people on
YouTube when the first people on Twitter
so I learned whatever like I think but
you know actually I got one I've been so
write so consistently that a lot of who
I am right now in this room telling
people to push the biggest lesson I had
to learn is I kept being so right but I
didn't squeeze every ounce out of it
when I was right
to use I don't play poker but to use the
analogy I would consistently have nuts
have the best hand but I wasn't going
all-in right like my great business
regret is I was right about Google
AdWords I ran Google AdWords the day
Google AdWords stuff started the day and
it was one of the biggest arbitrage as
ever
right and I took my dad's business from
3 to 60 and everybody gives me dabs for
that but always in my mind you know when
sometimes it and he took his families
you know when I'm getting announced in
at stage every time I'm like should have
been 250 because I should have been
harder and I've been saying it now for 3
years and a lot of people here who
follow me will tell you now that the
facebook arbitrage is not as good now
that they're starting to see the
Instagram have you been paying attention
Instagram last month it feels like it
started that you're not getting as many
likes and views as you did like I keep
telling people like this goes away it's
like but you know I don't know how long
people in real estate like you find a
new neighborhood that was stuff but then
I get gentrified and you bought one
house you know I should about seven so
the one lesson that I've up with and I
can team you to try and get better at is
when I've got it I squeeze the got it it
rule number 45 be brutally honest I
think we have to stop giving seventh
place trophies it's bad for kids I told
my son the other day my son is all about
sports now I told him right to his
beautiful little face the other day I'm
like he said to me dad how old am I
gonna be what I can dunk I said bro
you're never gonna dunk
he said why I said genetics but tennis
is great and it might be something you
know or you might buy a basketball team
but but what's really fun and this is
now me going through it right hypotheses
are cute executions different listening
to him three weeks later play with one
of his friends and he's telling his
friend to take jump shots like he's like
no no let's go out here and take shots
he goes and and he goes because we're
never gonna put it on him to that kid
won't dog either but but he goes cuz
we're never gonna dunk and Nick he goes
why goes because my dad told me and I
just keep playing it over in my mind me
being radically can Duras with him it's
gonna help him it's gonna help him be a
human that can deal with adversity and
things that don't come like like life
and it's gonna help him actually in
something he's passionate about because
if he just stays on the outside he could
be a nice little you know pickup
basketball player if he doesn't play
around the rim like every other idiot
that never gets to dunk and actually
works on a jump shot I don't know this
is something we need to bring back into
society merit accountability we need to
put these on pedestals not over coddling
fake environments rule number 46
do what you want once you start living
your life based on what your parents
expectations are or anybody else's
you've begun the process of not being
happy that is just the truth
who's happy doing something that they
don't want to be doing
nobody you may be content you may deal
with it but you're not happy I'm really
passionate about that I've been I've
become outrageously passionate about
keeping up with the Joneses as we call
it in America like in security it kills
you just you start doing things that you
can't afford
rule number 47 love the game I'm telling
you with my whole soul go meet anybody
who has known me for 40 years
I love losing I love it
love it I live for it here's why cuz I
think I deserve it if I play you won I
won and you be me
like what I'm not like I love the merit
of the game - I love entrepreneurship I
like when my companies fail or my
strategies fail or we lose a client I
love it I mean it I mean it I mean it I
mean it rule number 48 put out content
I'm telling you right now this is the
single most important thing in our
society when it comes to business if you
were not putting out content on the
Twitter Facebook Instagram LinkedIn
youtubes of the world you are becoming
vulnerable and irrelevant over time most
of you don't put out enough content
because you're trying to think about
what to say just filming yourself on
your hustle and talking about your tree
that's the content you need to put out
you have to make content for the
Internet content is the gateway drug to
growth in business in today's
environment
rule number 49 ignore the system I here
start tracking I'm like okay I'm gonna
start a Star Trek podcast then I'm gonna
take 18 months it's gonna pop dead I'm
gonna be able to you know I'll do
something on the side but then I'll be
able to start like selling hoodies which
Star Trek like I think I can become an
entrepreneur I think I can get to a
hundred thousand on any an idea but I'm
talented and I'm an entrepreneur it's
okay if you're not an entrepreneur but
it still speaks to its truth it is
possible and mate and like and if it's
not long-term like you didn't build it
then go get a job my thing is like you
could always get the job you could
always succumb
why are people starting by folding their
hand
[Music]
play because the system told you to vote
rant because it put you in detention if
you were rowdy and charismatic but I
didn't listen to you system I didn't
listen to you system I lived it because
I didn't respect it because I thought it
was a facade and I ended up being right
and rule number 50 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is have fun get
a pair one one vegetables overly empathy
bros a and if you had two hair one soft
cheese with a poppy rose a empty rows a
dish Oh with fish empathy Rose a like a
chicken yeah empathy Rose a maybe a
steak their empathy Rose a time to
finally if you did to spare it with a
dessert what would it be like a coconut
cream pie that or maybe just like a
sprinkle cupcake the empathy Rose a I
was fighting to stay alive the whole
time
oh I think you should do uh make a piece
of content that's like a spin the bottle
I'm gonna kiss one of you so get ready
the rock I know you've always wanted it
yeah
no we're gonna kill myself it's
literally nobody that was amazing
now I've got a special bonus tip from
Gary on how to ignore the opinions of
others that I think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
how can you live your hobby number two
is it time for you to go all-in and
number three what is the game that you
love to play the number one thing that I
think about every day is why do people
live their lives based on other people's
opinions
it is fascinating how many people are
dealing with the pressures of what their
parents want them to do versus what you
want to do this blue is right and the
reason you're wooing and the reason that
I'm most fascinated is I am fascinated
by watching parents parent their
children in the exact way that they
hated their parents parented them
it's it's remarkable to watch you would
think somebody who was forced to go to
university and become a doctor lawyer
engineer banker all that pain and
anguish that those years created you
would think that they were capable of
not repeating it but the problem is the
great insight of my life is how many
parents parent their children only and
100% based on what other parents think
about their children if you want more
garyvee top-50 check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there and if you don't adjust to the
reality of the situation you will be
completely left behind too many people
are executing or hoping
[Music]